ariana grande and Mac Miller call it  quits we do the power couple have gone  their separate ways after almost two  years of dating et has learned Ariana  and Mac quietly ended their romantic  relationship after their work schedules  became too hectic but the former pair  will remain the closest of friends  Ariana and Mac publicly announced they  were an item back in 2016 and the  Pittsburgh rapper was there for the 24  year old singer through the aftermath of  the Manchester bombing tragedy last year  the two have shared some pretty adorable  moments together as well  rocking hilarious Halloween costumes  goofing off on snapchat and most  recently cozying up at the Coachella  Music Festival last month and will never  forget their steamy makeout scene in her  music video for the way back in 2013  [Music]  [Applause]